nos toca una muestra para el
sexado genético
18 y medio
Vale y vamos a ver el total vamos a ver
te una muestra de la mucosa de la boca
Déjame así
un poco de
salir
estás para su ficha los dragones de
Komodo son difíciles de criar porque
varias razones una de las que estamos
encontrando en los últimos 20 años es
que las hembras tienen una alta
incidencia de enfermedades en el aparato
reproductor especialmente Pues cuando
van a ovular o cuando van a poner los
huevos
es una cosa que requiere una vigilancia
veterinaria muy frecuente
[Música]
revisar las fotos como tengo fotos de
nuestra postura
de la puesta de nuestra hembra de dragón
de Komodo sacamos un total de 12 huevos
de estos 12 huevos que los depósito el 3
de agosto solamente vimos que 5 sí que
parecían viables y los llevamos a una
incubación externa esta incubación
externa bueno la incubación en sí de los
dragoneses como no incubación larga es
de 8 meses durante estos ocho meses
Nosotros hemos recreado todo lo que
serían las condiciones en libertad
[Música]